so on my foraging journey I made this
one it's pure sugar imagine when you are
there starving and suddenly there is
sugar in a middle of that little thing
there you've got a little insects still
insects build a little house and inside
it's pure sugar all the tricks you can
use a lot of thing included water plant
Lotus plant and not all of them are
edible and not all of them are edible
raw some of them you cook them they lose
the toxicity you really have to know
what you're doing and this is the
knowledge by the way coming from the
Aboriginal people only this is not my
knowledge this is only from the
knowledge over those six thousand years
they've been living there and sometimes
when you are there are wondering
I never wondering why I'm out there I'm
wondering what it's out there because I
have to make a confession to you guys I
still don't know why I'm walking imagine
I've been all around the planet once
it's a Laura walking and I still don't
know we don't always have to know we
don't always have to know things you
know but the reality it's not what you
think it's what you feel and what you
think is what you feel swatch for you
you must do this is a really good day
this is like a five-star top left corner
we've got a little wood house it's like
a tumor in one type of a collectors
we've got a little hole in the middle
inside we've got a soft shell like
really soft soft shell and it's like a
little bed and inside the bed you've got
insect little grubs and you chuck that
in a fire cook a little bit when the
smokes get out of the little hole it's
cool
you can eat the bugs on the bed lovely
top red thing called dog balls really
sweet and powerful vitamin C really
difficult to find really rare grow in a
really high grass you really have to
have an eye for this one really happy to
find it because that will cut my hunger
at night on the right corner we've got
some really we call that while peach
doesn't taste like a peach at all it's
really sour but I like to have that in
my mouth to make my mouth watering
during the day and finally the main
five-star food will help me along the
way
a lot it's this one this is the bulb nut
the black nut comes from the Bob tree
and this tree teach me so much so this
is a amazing takeaway food see this
fruit this is the bottom nut and inside
you've got what I can hit it's a lot of
work always you know involved in that
process
so you have to do smash the little
powder thing inside you would find 15 to
20 little nuts and then those nuts
you have to roast them on a fire but not
too hot you have to make a fire take the
fire away and roast it under hot sand
and then only you can smash it between
two stone I start to eat the little
white meat inside it's a lot of process
and work but really good news right food
and actually can carry with me this is
amazing thing will be powerful food also
typical afternoon in my house hand of
the day
after really hot there because I have to
say it's really hot and during this time
because you've got two different time
where you can do this it's during the
wet season or the dry season I decide to
do the dry season thing more easy right
but there was also the bushfire season
so I will have this pressure constantly
of having my nose in a window the time
to smell what's going on in the air
because if there is a bushfire coming in
you need to react straight away knowing
then a bushfire goes for 40 kilometers
an hour is really fast so typically
there I've got this flat stone here and
I will be smashing the Boehm nuts on
that stone that's how I will eat and of
course fishing well this is those water
there they are salty water brackish as
they call that in Australia so you see
so they are tidal water on the bottom
you've got the sweet water and on the
top you've got the salt water so if you
want to drink some water you need to wet
then the tide goes down and only you can
drink water
so that's also tricky for fishing
because the pan of the tide you've got
the type of fish in it on all so you
kind of happy to have a fish right so
let me tell you a story about that fish
this fish eat toxic you've got this
little back finish it here on the spine
if you touch that not wrong to live
that's why I put a piece of food in his
mouth like that
so the first fish I'm an excellent
fisher woman really excellent because i
grew up we were going not in holiday we
were going fishing with my father i my
brother you know so i'm good at this so
the first fish that I actually took who
is like killed this fish were jumping
out of the water I will not be so happy
I can see still this fish jumping out
you know
neither next thing how he was like
splash Crocker that gets it I was like
really how that's how I'm gonna do these
things like I'm doing all the work and
they're gonna eat all of what not on my
watch it's always a solution right I've
been thinking a little bit I'm gonna get
you guys I noticed that I was doing more
I was doing a little noise on the top of
the water more they were attracted to
the noise right so I will do that and
then on purpose I will retrieve my stuff
I get to my second point
150 meters away and fish really quietly
here and grab my fish I go back to my
point
I say got one but I'm always a fair
player because I will always share my
food this is the rule in the bush is the
rule with nature I always share my food
so I will cut the fish take the guts out
the cut the head and I will give it to
those amazing friend of mine which is
the sword the sweet water crocodiles how
cute they are you know they're looking
look they're looking at you you cannot
fall in love with those things you know
and they are so passion and they are
there waiting then you give them
something that little puppy really but
become my friend and my soulmate out
there it was nobody no human no sign of
human only snakes crocodiles and them so
once I get the fish you have to still to
cook the fish so the best way to cook a
fish and be able to eat all of the meat
is to cook in the water simple like that
and interestingly I had some salt on
pepper with me never use it
I love the test of the food of the fiber
of
nature so sometimes when you are there I
had the chance to wash myself imagine so
this is a natural soap it's one
extremity of a eucalyptus tree so I took
this and if you smash it between your
hand in the water it's got a saturation
in saponin it's actually like a salt
it's amazing make you hair so shiny and
really works
really and the good thing also about
this trick its if you are in a small
Billabong you can actually do that in
that water and that will make a
saturation of oxygen in the water and
the fish living there will come up in a
surface with the tummy up looking for
oxygen
you just have to collect your dinner
thanks to the Amazon people so when you
up there like that you can all wash but
not like here right
one day it's a left-foot another day
it's a right one you know one little bit
after this anywhere in my country a good
cheese is a smelly cheese right so back
to the action this is a typical camp
thanks always to knife you notice in
case if I forgot one or if in case if I
lose one in emergency but I will never
sleep near the water it's the last thing
you have to do I will actually stay
there the water is just not far off
collect my food
fishing then that day I noticed some
tracks on the sand I saw there was
something goes around so rather than
giving my the inside guts of the fish to
the crocodile I will leave it on the
side because I know that would be little
forelegs friend coming in together
anyway I finished my day eat collect
everything walk off really
because those crooked ah you know they
can actually put the legs up and walk
five kilometres inland so you better
know why you're sleeping pretty high
herb right there was this typical thing
up there where crocodile eat German
people you know what happened those
German people get drunk and they are
feeling really powerful and they kind of
sleep near the water thinking you know
you're not gonna get me here like 20
meters from the water they sleep in the
town completely drunk
the crocodiles come at night take the
bottom of the tent and we draw the tent
get in the water and turn the tent and
the guy is inside that type of drunk and
he's going to the spin wash machine spin
and he doesn't know what's going on
until he's dead so all the story I was
aware of so really every single night I
will go in safe spot and so what does it
mean a safe spot where to go where to
find my way so I will study those
topographic map forever this is my
skills I'm so good with maps good ol
maps you know good compass' good ol maps
all I need well this map it's actually
dated in 1972 well because the
government doesn't do any new map from
there there is no need right so but the
mountains doesn't move right so I will
study those forever because the secret
is there you you have to listen to the
lungs care to be you know if you want to
find water you need to be the water so
if I was if I was the water if I was the
stream where I will go you have to
imagine if you want to find a fish you
need to be the fish because you need to
get in touch with who we are inside and
inside all of us here
the magical news that I've got to know
that we are animals we are mammals after
all Alfred
and the good thing about it it's we can
get in touch with that animality that
will help us a lot during everyday life
you know I use that a lot you know I
smell if I come near you or like I start
smelling you it don't worry too much
right really
we've got senses you know the
communication between two human beings
it's only seven percent on the
conversation on words the rest its
invisible
the rest is smell attitude feeling we
use our senses we don't realize at all
and out there it's the only thing you
can do get in touch with your animality
and when you starving you know I
remember in a Gobi Desert it's a
precious precious moment where after six
months of walking sweating painful body
I wake up open my turn
I mean a gobby it's nothing around me
only sand wind type of rocky thing
nothing too exciting open the thing and
suddenly that day I was like a little
ice cube melting in the Sun and I become
the wind the Sun the rocks I become one
with nature I believe today it's why I'm
actually walking is to get this link dis
touch with who we are touch with where
we've got the feet on we are on this
planet all of us we do not have
boundaries we belong to this planet this
is the magic of it well it's really good
diet after three weeks I lose 12
kilogram it's quite quick fast really
walking 12 hours a day try to catch my
food it was quite really a difficult
task
but that was not to forget my
determination in this journey how we can
be so determinate how we can go for our
dream that bad
well it is not recipe because the
currency sweat pain but happiness yes
happiness fun sense of humor do not
forgot your sense of humor this is the
most important thing you will have with
you all you lie that's what I've got in
my survival kit first when people ask me
what you've got in your surviving kit my
sense of you more do not walk out of the
door without it because you need it see
when you've got this kind of terrain to
cross this is a swamp
I need to cross that swamp and on the
bottom of that swamp
there is water big hole in some places
and inside those hole you've got
crocodiles and snakes falling from the
tree and big wild bull frozen ball not
moving hearing you moving through those
dry panda no leaves
see the flow is full of those panda new
leaves dry one so where were you doing
you making too much noise they hear you
coming in it's like playing a little bit
with the life you've got so you have to
trust something in one stage you have to
trust in your capability of melting with
nature because I know I'm in the right
spot I know that what I'm doing it's
what I we're supposed to be and this is
the only way to understand nature if
every one of us here tonight know where
they belong to it's a magical step to
take so I was in this building before I
leave for the six
talking with the senior photographer
editor here and she was saying to me
well Sara you know you don't want video
crew with you but can you just do one
concision imagine if if I give you a
photographer like few days like imagine
six day before the end of your journey
I get the photographer on location and
for the word fulfill of you I would why
you know make concession a little bit
you know you have to be flexible a
little bit I said well okay let's do
this in one collision has to be a cute
male photographer right imagine about
there for so long and she say okay I do
my best helicopter arrived and this is
the person who walk out I do not know
what this woman didn't understand about
the cute photographer that was a woman
and I can see this woman walking off the
chopper the helicopter say hi I'm
crystal I look at her say you know the
man she was a bit shocked you know she I
had a little briefing before she's done
knowing that I'm not gonna be that easy
to go to work with you know and anywhere
we go on this amazing trip she was
unbelievable all the crazy picture you
saw amazing picture that's come from her
her name is crystal right she's amazing
photographer National Geographic
photographer and on the top of it she
played a game she's been really foraging
for her own food also she knows all
about bush tucker by now and when we
when we we walk together at night you
know we exhausted really we make a
little fire for the sake of it really
boy some hot water I'll be starving
going to bed counting the day is like
four days to go you know but at the end
of the day when the light is off in her
little 10 because I will have my little
turn she would have a
the night is quiet I will hear some
wrapping paper going on like what
darling
what's going on oh you don't want to
know no I do want to know talk to me at
least talk to me you know like I can
handle this
I want to know curiosity it's not one
mine one of my 40 you know I need to
know she talked to me she said okay
flatbread with tuna because it was awful
off of course she would bring food with
her you know she's working and so every
night we will have this little game
going on at night to my little I was
like okay three days to go Sarah you can
do this you know every night was getting
more difficult I will be more serving
and one night I hate this unusual noise
really looks like a jar plastic jar
thing yeah and I said okay new this is
new right she said no no no no yeah no
that's new I never heard of peak and she
couldn't speak pretty much she had
something in her mouth like what is it
their home nothing
hmm nothing really say talk to me
it's Nutella she was eating Nutella with
the spoon seriously anyway she taste my
power inside me and we will make joke
about it on during the journey she would
wait really at the end of the day to
actually eat something in her turn not
tempting me or not he'll be eating in
front of me so the magic of those Joanie
the magical way of walking through this
planet I've been doing this for 23 years
whoa basically everywhere what I what I
can't take out with me if I have to take
one phrase out will be this one let you
so touched yours go walking because it
is the most beautiful thing we can do
get this connection with the planet and
feel connected to the universe and have
faith on what we what we what we are at
other spaces in this planet because we
are all connected that we wanted on not
we are the spiderweb of people connected
to each other and the only thing we can
do it's really understand this
connection that we've got with each
other on the planet and start to look
after her because after all the planet
doesn't need hers we need the planet and
this is my arrow my mum my cute little
mom she will support me all through my
childhood my adult life and she was this
really smart so she will say to me Sarah
do you want to do your homework
Oh clean your room well I had the choice
right so she's been this really smart
and credible mom supporting me and she
doesn't know word in English
she doesn't travel at all but she will
be there on location in every expedition
I will finish
she'll be there for me and on the left
it's my assistant slash cousin all the
family is involved in my expedition and
one day I did the last bit the last step
and it looked like this there is this
hurt inside me would take me out there
walking again and again and again and
again because I've been doing this for
23 years
I know the this really strange feeling
which is like a link with nature a
direct connection with nature than love
God
I know I will follow that came again to
go back again to make sure we like to
feed because I believe human can get
them normally reason to again
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]